there is one corner of Europe where you
can see a reminder of what life used to
be like a few short weeks ago in the
spring sunshine people in the Swedish
capital Stockholm were carrying on as if
the pandemic had never happened
Sweden has gone against the grain in not
closing down restaurants or limiting
people's movements much but with over
2,000 dead has a worse outcome so far
than its scandinavian neighbors the
government is starting to sound a bit
worried about its own guidance attacked
mouthwash alone coma from saw as the
spring Sun appears we seem to be seeing
whirring reports about full outdoor
terraces and restaurants people in
crowded places and we have to take this
seriously let me be extremely clear I
don't want to see any crowded outdoor
restaurant terraces in Stockholm or
anywhere else and everyone has to take
this on his or her responsibility
Germany has the opposite problem under
the iconic Brandenburg Gate in Berlin
restaurants have staged a protest by
lining up hundreds of empty chairs
because the authorities across the
country have refused yet to countenance
than reopening despite a far lower death
rates than countries like Sweden and
unlike Sweden Germany is continuing most
testing opening drive-through facilities
to trace more and more people ministers
insist life can't go back to anything
like normal until the infection rates
drop to the hundreds every day in terms
of health care it makes perfect sense
but the tension with the demands of
business is growing
restaurant owners have run out of
patience mostly what Holmes understood
it's no exaggeration to say the sheer
panic imagine your business which is
doing very well is shut down from one
day to the next it means we don't have
less revenue it means we have no revenue
but leases and costs continue it will
hardly be a consolation but in most
countries going out to socialize remains
a faraway dream like enjoying the haute
cuisine of the French bistro that too is
almost certainly many months away the
answer should it be a good affair
nothing would be worse than conducting a
rushed reopening of restaurants and bars
which could then force us to close again
I think it would be an ax men
disappointment not only for the
restaurant owners but also for the
French people it's also worth
remembering that many of the most
vulnerable like the elderly of the
Spanish city of El Cajon couldn't afford
to go out to eat even if the option was
open to them here their Spanish Red
Cross is delivering food instead at the
sharp end of the virus keeping people
alive remains the priority Laurence Lee
al-jazeera